[BLANK_AUDIO]
This course is about software design focusing on high level
architectural design rather than detail design. It is not a programing course.
In particular, you should already know how to program in
at least one programing language in order to succeed in this course.
It is also not an introductory software engineering course. A prerequisite of
the course is that you have already been introduced to this subject,
even by another course or because you have worked as a developer in a software
development organization. This course focuses on object-oriented design, and
the projects make use of the Java programming language. Experience with these
topics is not strictly required, but familiarity will help.
If you want a refresher, the class resources page linked to
from the instructor's notes points to video lectures I prepared on these topics.